here we go I'm gonna go first and then
involve some of the people on my team
this is my best Chewbacca
impersonation what's that believe nation
happy Star Wars day or may the fourth
day may the fourth be with you I have
partnered up with UNICEF because they
are doing a roar for Change challenge
the idea here is they want influencers
to roar like Chewbacca they're ready
it's coming see how great my Chewbacca
roar is and any time anybody uses the
hashtag roar for change on Twitter or
Instagram Disney will be donating $1 to
UNICEF so this is for fun this is for a
good cause if you guys like this video
yes you can leave a comment down below
but those comments do not count towards
the donation so you have to go to
Twitter or you have to go to Instagram
hashtag roar for change and every time
somebody does that an extra dollar is
given by Disney to UNICEF so great cause
hopefully you will support it all right
here we go I'm gonna go first and then
involve some of the people on my team
this is my best Chewbacca
impersonation watch I should probably
listen to what does Chewbacca sound like
how is that could I be Chewbacca I feel
like I have the height with you baka I
might need a little more hair mm-hmm one
more shot at the noise that's it that's
my room that's my roar for change guys
now I'm gonna throw it over to some of
the people on my team the people that
you know and love here's their version
of Chewbacca Hayden let's hear you roar
for change
okay now let's hear you roar for change
are you here I already said there are a
that my voice cracked a bit
can I deal once just load it on your
phone listen to it turn off that fan so
we can hear it we need a NEMA and high
quality voice look at that face of
nervousness and excitement those
youtubers trying to make money
unbelievable unbelievable dude that was
good
I listen Chewbacca that Chewbacca was
better than my Chewbacca
that's the original Chewbacca the team
was not that impressed okay once one
more time with heart Nina here it comes
that's really good high five in a row
for change
we got films okay we have a special
project I need you to roar like
Chewbacca every personnel who tweets or
instagrams with the hashtag roar for
change they donate a dollar what they're
asking people to do is make a video of
people roaring like Chewbacca
so chew see th e W yeah Rory
oh the ads the ads this is the moment
we've all been waiting for what's
happening here
[Music]
okay
yeah that's it there you go yeah that's
it
here comes that was good
Chewbacca roar okay guys go tweet it out
hashtag war for change well you got
Teemo interested okay he's on guard now
he's on guard okay Alex I need you to
roar like Chewbacca mad respect Alex for
just doing it anyway I can't might not
even know a word about so that's high
five there alright
so we want to hear you roar like
Chewbacca so that if you guys like
Alex's roar then you go to Twitter and
Instagram and put hashtag roar for
change
I'm shaking too much
I'm sorry for the shaking guys I'm
laughing too hard at this okay look at a
video and then do it well this is her
charity so you get to be ready okay shoo
okay the first thing that comes up
all right here we go this is what you
bought Association absorbs co2
commercials all right come on come on
come on so much skip skip skip eight
seven six five
oh yeah I got to hear what's bad oh come
on
six point four thousand people like this
is insane okay
[Music]
it's like you're drunk but you're trying
to talk yeah teemo's very curious why
what's happening here Rises how about
you baka scene roar for change alright
good job Alex alright so that was a lot
of fun to put together hopefully you
guys enjoyed and how to laugh like I did
in doing it and in watching my team do
it again this is for a good cause is for
UNICEF please please please yes you
could leave a comment below but if you
want to help the cause you can make a
video you can do other things to help
just support it but really what I need
you to do is go to Instagram or go to
Twitter and put in hashtag roar for
change you can look at the video you can
have a special message whatever you want
as long as it's hashtag roar for change
because it's Star Wars day may the
fourth may the fourth be with you every
time you that Disney will give $1 to
UNICEF and so it's a lot of fun it's for
a good cause
thank you guys so much for the support
believe nation Rox I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and I'll see you soon thank you for the
support if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details